I'll give you a quick introduction to
Erlang a programming language which was
developed by the Computer Science
Laboratory in the late 80s and then
released as open source in the late 90s
actually this is oh it's the Erlang give
comment let it crash you know so so
crashes are good with their long run yes
because what you do is you sold the
problem that way most programming
languages the history is completely
irrelevant but in the case of airline
you know the team who invented it we're
actually out to solve a problem they
were out invent a programming language
and whatever instead task to do was
figure out how do we build the next
generation of telecom switches you know
back then near the telecom switches with
only systems which were massively
scalable so this was before the internet
they had to be reliable they could never
fail there were incredibly complex this
was happening at the same time as the
hotel car industry being in a state of
transitions they were going from single
service networks where you had a phone
network only thing you could do is fall
you had internet you know and the only
thing you could do was basically your
connect to the internet or mobile
networks no anything you could do is
call other mobile phones and what was
happening was that they were all merged
the systems were all slowly being merged
into a kind of multi service network
developing these systems you know with
the deregulation of the telecom markets
time to market became critical so you
know the large telcos didn't have all
the time they wanted to develop the
systems as they had in the previous
decades
if you know now all of a sudden whose
competitions in the market so if a
provider telco provider couldn't
couldn't you provide a particular system
they go to the competitors and and the
same applied you know two to two users
if you weren't happy with bt in the 80s
you were stuck with bt in the 90s you
could change when they're trying to
solve the problem of developing next
generation of switches what they did is
they took all of the existing that or
many of the existing languages at the
time and you know the prototype telecom
at
vacations and after few years came to
the conclusion that no all of these
languages had a lot of desirable
features but there was no one language
which had them all and that's when they
decided to start inventing a programming
language and you know spent another you
know three four years prototyping what
eventually became Erlang one of the main
features which increased programmer
productivity were the declarative was
the declarative aspects of a language
declarative programming gives you a much
higher level of abstraction and it gives
you smaller concise programs which are
easier to read but also most importantly
to maintain let's not forget yet they
will look at how to reduce the
maintainability costs of of their
systems and yeah actually studies later
on discovered that you're comparing say
Erlang to C++ or Java academic studies
showed that airline consisted of 4 to 20
times less code than their counterparts
in imperative and object-oriented
programming languages and these are your
similar numbers near which you'll see in
Haskell and others and it is an it is an
attribute of functional programming so
just to give you a quick example a
little taste over what an airline
program it looked like let's just do
factorial of 3 we'll write a little
program so factorial of zero returns 1
factorial of n when n is greater than or
equal to 1 returns n times factorial of
M minus 1 so n here is a variable it's
an upper case and what we do is we use
something called pattern matching to
understand which of these two function
clauses we execute it so if we call
factorial 3 we try to pattern match 3 to
the 0 it fails so we go on to the next
clause and n is a number variable so
gets bound to 3 3 is greater than or
equal to 1 so we call 3 times factorial
of n minus 1 so it's free times
factorial of 2 2 will fail patter magic
appear
we'll pass a match here and it's now
gets rebound 2 to 2 is greater than
equal to 1 so we call 2 times factorial
of 1 and it won't had a match up here it
will pattern match here so we end up
calling 1 times factorial of zero 0 now
we'll Pat a match in the first clause
which is our base case we return a 1 and
at this point we do 1 x 1 x 2 x 3 and
return 6 note a few things here the
variables inner length or single
assignment that means that once you've
bound them to a value you cannot change
them so they're immutable this shouldn't
actually be called variables because you
can't you can't change it but whenever
you call them in you recall the function
it's considered fresh you know whenever
you re enter the function clause and
also there's another property in here
which is that of defensive programming
defensive programming is not encouraged
so if we call factorial of negative 1
for example it will fail pattern
matching up here because negative 1 is
not equal to 0 we will be bound to end
here but negative 1 is not greater than
or equal to 1 so this Clause will also
fail at this point there are no more
clauses but one of the function clauses
has to always succeed if it doesn't the
actual process executing this particular
code terminates and it terminates
because of a bug I mean you shouldn't be
calling factorial with a negative 1 so
by not encouraging defensive programming
and instead letting the process
executing the code crash if your state
gets corrupted results in very compact
and concise programs which are very easy
to rain you program for the positive
case and we'll see later how we handle
these errors we don't ignore them we
just have them slightly differently than
what you might be used to so now we've
looked now at the declarative aspects
but your actual program your main
building blocks when working with
variant programs is concurrency their
processes and you know process is an
airline don't share memory so they're
based on immutable state and your
there's action another video where we
look at you know concurrency models with
a mutable state and mutable state as
well now processes are lightweight
processes so they're detached from the
underlying operating system back in the
days when we could have a maximum of 16
or 32 August Fred's the virtual machine
could actually handle near hundreds or
even thousands of processes running and
running concurrently and that's near
that that was a very wise decision to
detach the concurrency model from the
underlying operating system as it allows
you to design for scale irrespective of
the target architecture so that means
airlines handling the threads is that
right that is correct so divert airline
runs in a virtual machine and the
virtual machine can be seen as an
operating system on top of the operating
system so I wouldn't call them Fred's
but lightweight processes the virtual
machine itself runs on one or more
threads you know depending on if you're
running on a multi-core architecture so
we've got processes in Erlang and your
processes are created using spawn
building functions so we call spawn
where we pass in a module a function and
a list of 0 or more arguments and in
less than a microsecond in the sub
microseconds a new process is created
which is running this function in this
module with these arguments and you know
initially this process takes up very
little memory just a few K and so it
just changes the way you model your
programs because for every concurrent
activity in your system you'll actually
go in and create a process so imagine an
instant messaging server what you would
do is for every message coming in coming
out every login request every status
update sex telling your buddies I'm
online or I'm gone offline will actually
be a process executing that particular
code and you know once it's executed you
know the process terminates a virtual
machine today can handle you know tens
of millions of processes in the VM
itself and it makes reasoning about your
program very easy because you just need
to think in terms of a single message
and then the VM itself will allow you to
scale you know way beyond that processes
yeah do not share memory they
with each other through message-passing
and so you know when when we spawn a new
process the spawn built-in function will
return a process identifier which we
here bind to the variable pit and this
process here now can send a message to
this other process so here we're sending
an atom hello an atom is just a constant
literal it's what you see is what you
get so it's used for comparison and it's
used for mainly readability and so a
copy of this atom gets made and stored
into the process mailbox of this other
process the key points here is these are
lightweight processes they are they
don't share memory and they communicate
with each other through message passing
and your virtual machines are incredibly
powerful and can can scale you know to
tens of thousands and even millions of
processes if need be so I was saying
earlier that you try to avoid defensive
programming in Erlang and if something
goes wrong because of a bug in your
program because your state is corrupt
you let your process terminate and you
know when a process terminates you
basically lose that process and you lose
that state but all of the other
processes around it will continue
executing so you imagine a phone switch
where each process represents a phone
call a bug in your program would cause
you to terminate one process which is
handling a phone call you drop one phone
call but all of the other thousands of
phone calls going on and in parallel in
your system wouldn't be affected and so
it's a form of isolation of isolating
versus saying you know you get a bug in
a Fred you're a Fred usually will handle
many more phone calls you know that Fred
terminates all of the phone calls in
that Fred will be terminated even if
they were not the cause of the of the
bug or the corrupt date in the first
place so you know this this isolation
however needs to be controlled and we do
that through something we call
supervisors we use supervisors to
encourage the whole your program for the
correct case paradigm and learning
processes crash or terminate when
something goes wrong and the whole idea
behind
supervise it is that of layering so we
will have a site top level supervisor
which is a process here I'll denote it
as a little square and supervisors have
a property of being able to monitor
other processes and if they terminate
catch and exit so you know assume we've
got a process here which is monitoring
200 processes one is just a regular
process that is a supervisor if one of
these processes terminates the
supervisor which is trapping exits will
receive an exit signal and based on this
X is signal it can decide what to do it
could either restart the process so
assume it's a process storing some data
was a phone calls ongoing but it's
actually not responsible for that phone
call we restart a process so when that
data is needed other process can go in
and access sou we would just restart it
or if it's a process responsible for a
phone call it would just terminate that
process the phone call would be dropped
and it wouldn't restart it and what
would then happen is when you know you
soak the phone calls dropped you blame
it on the network you redial and then a
new process with a fresh state will be
will be created and hopefully you're
nothing's going to go wrong at that
point so it's the whole idea of
isolating but there will be times when
you know the supervisor realizes that
just restarting the process won't solve
the problem so what they do is it will
go in and terminate all of the other
processes in its sub tree and then
terminate itself sending an exit signal
up to its supervisor and the top level
supervisor then decides what to do it
could be that this process down here is
crashing with of corrupt state in here
so you know this supervisor might then
decide to terminate this process and
then restart it then restart the sub
level supervisor which you know when new
phone calls and come in would get added
here and if the top level supervisor
realizes that a can solve the problem it
will itself terminate taking down the
whole supervision tree and the program
with it and at that point that's maybe
when you go in and you reboot the
Machine you reboot or restart the
virtual machine you know as the problems
might be
see the whole error handling mechanism
as an onion we're on a smallest level
you've got aid your sequential error
handling your sequential code you then
do it on a process level you'd then do
it on a supervision tree level then the
next core is on a virtual machine level
where you restart the virtual machine
and then you've got it on a machine
level Aaron Lang is you know the first
programming language I'm aware of which
actually embedded distribution into the
semantics of the language so we've got
two processes which are running on a
single machine here and process a
communicates to process B you know my
message passing we'd seen earlier that
you know we use the exclamation mark
hello to send a message to that process
now using the same syntax you know we
could have process C running on a
separate note and you know we've got the
network in between and what process I
could do is take the process identify
err of C and send it the message hello
and this message now will be sent
straight to C so being the same syntax
by writing a program which runs on a
single machine with very little changes
or by doing it right from the start you
can actually distribute it across a
cluster of machines without you know we
are having to do any major changes in
the business logic of your system as
soon as you solve the problem of
distribution what you automatically get
is the ability to scale on multi-core
architectures and because in effect the
multi-core multi-core is yeah it has
very similar principles to to
distribution and you're guessing I
assume we've got two cords and we've got
five processes running you know we put
three he throws it on one core and to
first to another they communicate with
each other through message passing and
it doesn't matter if your discourse are
on the same chipset or under learn
different chipsets on the same machines
or they're actually on separate machines
all we need to do is you know used a
bang hello to communicate with this
process be it on the same core or on
different course and the concurrency
model earning has is based on no shared
memory you're the biggest problem to
your scanning on multi-core is
memory lock contention you know it's the
the feature which slows down the whole
scalability on them and so what you do
is you pick a programming language with
a concurrency model based on no shared
memory and that solves a problem for
either this is going to be an iterative
process and what we want to do is move
these things around and permute them so
if this is our data path with our
columns by sharing bytes around with
different columns when we combine it
with the mixed column step which we'll
do in a minute you'll see that actually
we're mixing everything up so within
just a couple of rounds everything is
very very jumbled up